Happy Thursday, everybody.
And welcome back to the
data science hangout.
And let's see if we remember
how to do this today.
We were on bit of
a break for July.
This is so excited to
see everybody back here.
Hope everyone's
having a great week.
If this is your first
time joining us today,
I know this is a pretty
big group here today.
So it's so nice to meet you.
Thank you for spending your
Thursday. With all of us.
If we haven't met yet,
I'm Rachael Dempsey.
I lead our pro
community here at Posit.
And the data science hangout
is our open space to chat
about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across
different industries.
And so every Thursday,
we feature a different
data leader from the community.
And together,
we're all dedicated to making
this a welcoming environment for everybody.
So we love hearing from
everyone in this environment no
matter your level of
experience or area of work.
This is a casual conversation
of this all here,
but it's totally okay to just
listen in too, but there's
always three ways that you
could jump in and ask questions
or provide your own
perspective too.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on zoom.
You can put questions in the
zoom chat And feel free to
always put a little star next to it
if you want me to read it instead.
Maybe you're in a coffee
shop or something.
Or I could call on you
to to ask your question and introduce
yourself. And then lastly,
we also have a slide o
link where you can ask questions anonymously
and Hannah or someone from the
team will share that in the
chat. Oh, you already
did. Thank you.
Well, I am so excited to
be joined by my cohost today for
the Data Science
Hangout, Hadley Wickham,
Hadley is chief scientist at
Posit and builds tools to make
data science easier, faster, and
more fun. You might know
Hadley's work for
packages like tidyverse,
including g g plot
two and deeplier,
much more. But, hardly,
I'd love to have you
introduce yourself.
If you tell us something you
like to do outside of work too
and a little bit about what it
means to be chief scientist here at Posit.
Sure thing. Thanks for
Thanks for having
me, Rachel, for,
finally inviting me. I'm starting
to get a little hurtful, but,
glad I could finally make
it. Thanks for joining.
Like outside of
work, I'd say the,
here's
Ever dog. It's Lola.
It's a thirteen year old Shope,
and that's pretty much what
she does these days. It's sleep.
I write books.
I work at one ninety nine.
This is one of my this is
one of my books that I wrote recently,
to the cocktail book because
I'm also reading the cocktails.
This was,
because I mean all the data
for the cocktail is stored in a
YAML file, and then
it uses quarto to,
turn it into book,
and I'll show you
because it's a lot to kind of so
it has like a table of contents. Like,
the primary organization
of the book is by spirit.
But,
because I'm extra,
it also has one index
that lists all other
primary ingredients in the
cocktail. So if you wanna find,
like, something to use on
a secure, and then finally,
It has an index by name.
So if you remember the name
of the cocktail, I wanna find it.
So these are, like, fixing
the things that, like,
annoy me about cut out books
that you can never find the
cocktail that you're looking
for because they're ordered in
some like arbitrary
thing and the
indexes are so bad.
So thanks to the
the power of Corto and,
latex and make index. It was
really easy to make a super
highly index book
with few r scripts.
I have to ask you, what's
your favorite from that book?
Dude, it's the
favorite cocktail.
I am enjoying cocktails I'm
enjoying the most at the moment.
I'm not actually in that book
because I only discovered them, recently.
And
I can't even remember what
it's called, but it uses,
it's rum it's an equal
parts cocktail. There's rum fire
Aperol, yellow chartreuse,
and lime juice, and rum fives,
it's kinda like a
crazy overproof.
Jamaican on. Sounds great.
I see there's a lot of,
fans here in the chat.
But, but, hardly, would love to
have you share with everybody here.
What does it actually mean
to be chief scientist at Posit?
What do what do you
do on a daily basis?
Good question.
So I can know, these days,
I'm I manage a a team,
the tidyverse team
who's responsible
for kinda not only the
tidyverse packages,
but also many of the
packages and the package development
ecosystem, so test
that in dev tools,
use this in roxgen And then
also some kind of lower level
packages that
underpin these things,
which often live in the
outlook GitHub organization.
But, like, management is not
my ashen. I would say in my,
like, I do okay.
But it's not like what I really
enjoy and it's not where I want
to spend my time. So I
tried still spending as much time as
I possibly can. Like,
writing both code
and a box.
So I I recently kind of
realized I just felt like I
felt like I hadn't.
Been, like, getting
that much done.
And I think it was it felt
like I just sort of recognized,
like, oh, that felt like it
was probably mostly in my head,
but then I realized The key
reason I found that way is that
it wasn't working
on a book project.
So, like, my when I
am working on a book,
I like I always get up that's
the first thing I do for the
first hour or two
in the morning.
And it's now, I've
seemed to be, like,
addicted to writing books so
that when I'm not writing a
book, I feel weird
and uncomfortable.
So now that I've started
work on the the next book,
which is gonna be called
something like Patty design principles,
things are feeling
much better. So, yeah,
so I do some management.
I like writing books,
and then obviously,
like, writing R code.
And recently,
the packages I've been working
on are not tidy those packages,
but I've just been kind
of diving in around positive
various open source packages and
kind of seeing where I can
pitch in and help out. So
about a year ago, I guess,
a long guy who helped
out on the PIM's package,
then more recently,
I've been working on
the RS Connect package,
which helps you deploy your apps
to connect and the RN package.
Which helps you create
reproducible environments via our code.
So if anybody ever feels
like you're not doing enough,
write a book, Hey.
And I will say like my I
will say like my advice for writing
a book is that it's easy. You
just have to write for an hour.
Or it's simple. I should say.
He's at the right for an hour
every day for a year in the end
of it. I have a book.
And as far as I know,
no one has ever successfully
followed that advice.
Not very good advice.
So we have a really big
crew here today. So I'm gonna repeat
how people can, like,
ask questions and jump into
because I know a few people
joined after, and it's so
nice to see you all here.
If this is your first time
joining, so nice to meet you.
This is an informal casual
conversation with us all here
so you can ask questions and
chat with us in a
variety of ways.
So you could raise
your hand on Zoom,
and I'll be able to see that.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And then Hannah will share a
slide link again here where you
can ask questions
anonymously too.
Just wanna make sure I
said that in case somebody joined
after I I put it there.
But I see Mike Smith, you
had a question in the chat.
Do you wanna jump
in here first?
Yeah. Thanks. So this is,
I don't know if if you can
answer it directly, Hadley,
but if you can kind of
give us a feel for it,
So the tiny versus huge. It's
a a massive number of packages,
massive number of developers.
How does Pause it kind of
herd the cats and making sure that
all of these
different development pieces come
together and work
together effectively.
Yeah. I would I'd say most of
that is just like we talk a lot
amongst the team, and we
talk pretty frequently about
like, what, you know, like,
what when we're designing APIs?
Like, why do we favor this
design over that design? Like,
if we've got something
that's that's, you know,
important or complex.
Like, that that's something we'll
talk over in a team
meeting. And that is
Like having multiple people
think about these problems,
I think, is is just the
key because it's two.
It really is past the point
that any one per person can
keep it all in their head.
And it's very easy to
accidentally introduce con
inconsistencies because you've forgotten
how some function you
wrote ten years ago works.
So, tight just like
that, a lot of, you know,
we're a pretty close knit
team that works closely together.
That's really important.
The other thing
which I'm working on which I can
pop a link to in the chat
is this book called,
tidy design principles.
Which is where, like,
now I'm trying to write up
some of these principles,
which is like useful, you know,
it's useful for us because
it encode, you know,
codes them in writing
and we can look them up.
But it was also
hopeful, hopefully useful for the
community. So you
can both, like,
see the patterns
we follow and get
more of a glimpse into kind of
like how we think about these things.
So the goal is to have
both kind of these are things you
should do, but also like Like,
this is what we were thinking
when we designed this
interface. Like, these
are the things, like,
these are the trade
offs we considered.
These are all of the
options we considered.
Is why we rejected this one
for this one. And then, you know,
looking back now, like, do
we regret those choices? Like,
would we have made different choices
if we knew then, what we knew?
You now.
I was waiting to see if you
had a follow-up there. Mike,
I saw you nodding.
I see
talking is definitely,
you know, the a one tip,
but, but it I can
imagine it, you know,
from a project
management perspective,
it must be difficult to to
ensure that all of these things
just, you know, because
they're like lego pieces.
You want them to just
clip together. Right?
Yeah. Yeah.
I'm definitely something we spend
a lot of time thinking
about. So I
see Point a few questions
starting to come in now here.
Andy, I see you
asked a question
in the chat about,
some of the books.
Do you wanna jump in
here? Yes. Thanks.
Just hadley, I I
saw you, I think,
post on LinkedIn the other
day or somewhere about the upcoming
book. Is there a Is there
a difference between
the design principles
and say, like,
the our cookbook or our
recipes? Or is that is it kind
of an extension of those.
Yeah. So I
and I've written a lot
of books about that now.
But I would say, like, you
know, I think of, like,
off of data science is,
like, if you're, you know,
if you wanna live out of
your data science, then
advanced r is if you wanna
learn how r works as a
programming language.
And there's kind of this
gap in between them. Like,
how do you go from you
know, someone being a date, just a,
you know, a data scientist
who is analyzing,
like individual data sets
someone who's starting to
design, like, kind of bigger
pieces of code, like functions
that you can use in
multiple analysis So maybe eventually
you collect enough of those
functions you wanna do a package.
So, like, how do you, like,
when you're writing a function,
like, What do you think
about? Like, how do you, like,
how do you pick the arguments?
How do you name the arguments?
How do you choose how
they should interact?
So hopefully, I think
this is not, you know,
this is a book
that's, you know,
you've gotta be fairly far
along in your your journey with
r and data science because now
you're right wanting to write the functions.
But I think this is a pretty this
is sort of a gap in the current
selection of our books,
which compared to
other programming languages,
just to have far fewer books
on kind of like, you know, general
programming topics,
like, like design,
Thank you.
Okay. I'm gonna ask a
question over from Slido.
And as a reminder, you
can ask questions anonymously there too.
But one was have you learned
anything particularly
noteworthy about
the Python community
and or space since
posits rebranding?
Yes.
I I don't know, like, I
don't know how to put this without.
Steaming me, but I don't know.
It just feels like the
Python data science,
but it's just like so
hard to do data science.
But there's like so many
things that are, like, annoying from,
like, the environment
management problem to doing
things that I feel like they
should be simple in pandas to,
like, you know,
I don't know. Just be also I'm
a to continue to be amazed that
people are as productive
as they are in Python,
then they have their with
the tools they have on hand.
And so I think one of
the things I'm kind of excited
about is, like,
Positive, you know,
starts to contribute to the space
is how can we kind of
bring our magic of, like, it
just works into this space so
that people can just, like,
do data science in Python
without without having to worry
about all of these kind
of extraneous things that that
interesting to data scientists.
Thank you.
Smeid dot IC, you had asked
a question in the chat.
Do you wanna jump in here?
Yeah. So head this is
a question for Henry.
When you design packages, how do you
factor in security given
the increasing number of tracking
and other attacks that
are happening in the enterprise
space these days. Thank you.
Yeah.
I would security is a diff
a a difficult one because I think
in most, like, most of the tidy
biz, it just doesn't, like,
really apply. Like, you know,
you don't have to worry about security
in g g book too, for example,
like,
we we think about it more
in the packages that have to
require authentication.
So typically, you know,
when you're getting data,
whether it's from
an a or a database,
you're going to need
to store those credentials somehow.
And one of the things
I've been thinking about in particular,
recently as I've been working
more on, like, you know,
using our pro
products is like you,
how do you make sure
those credentials
travel kind of both
seamlessly and securely
from wherever you're doing the
analysis to wherever you're deploying.
The analysis.
So, apparently, I think
we're at the stage.
There's a a lot around, like,
how do we help users learn the
right conventions,
like you should never
be typing your password
into the console
because if you do that,
it's easy for it to end up
save in your dot history file,
and it's easy to accidentally
commit that to git.
And now you've shared your
password with a much wider
range of people
than you should be.
So at the moment,
there's not adding a lot of
use of environment variables,
which are a little bit safer.
At least because you're not
storing them literally in in
your code, but how can we
do better at, you know, providing tools
with for
saving those securely,
and then we needed, like,
sharing them across from your
computer to connect or the to
shiny apps or whatever. I
think lots, lots of questions there,
not a lot of answers currently.
Sanjay, I see you had a
question in the chat earlier
too. Do you wanna jump in here?
Yeah. Hi, Huddl.
One thing which always
intrigued me is our company
always looked at purchasing the
post it. Our studio connect or
post it connect. But we never
got a proper sales pitch and
could you articulate what advantages,
posted our studio connect has
over the open source version, please?
Yeah. So I would say, like, the
the reason why you want connect
or that it's kind of like main
value proposition to me
is it helps get your data
analyses out of the hands
of data scientists and into the
hands of decision makers.
And at the end
of the day, like,
it doesn't matter
how awesome you are.
The data scientists this,
unless you can show
your results to people, your
analyses, people in your
organization who actually need
them. And so Connect is really
about, like, publishing,
whatever you're doing in our,
to what to to inform that other
people in your organization
could see whether it's like
shiny apps or Amark quarter documents
or if you wanna turn
those into, like,
a scheduled report so that
people are getting emailed to
nine AM every day with latest
results in your dashboard.
It's all about, like,
sharing what you're doing
as a data scientist.
And and, ideally, or,
like, the goal of connect,
which not like a hundred
percent of the way there,
but we're trying to get
there, in the long run.
Very much the goal is to go
to do that just by like pushing a
button in your rstudio wherever
you're doing the analysis,
it should just be a single
click or a single function call
to keep that up. So you
can stay focused on,
you know, the data analysis
rather than having to worry
about, like, running a web
server, securing a web server,
making all the authentication
is working, Make
sure your emails,
jobs are getting sent out
correctly. And when those jobs fail,
that you could notify that they
didn't work and all that kind
of other. Stuff,
which is like really necessary for
a product like this to work,
but probably you don't care
about as a data scientist in
thinking about it just gets in
the way of doing your doing
your most modern work.
But but quite a lot of it
is achieved from our to our studio
open source server also.
Isn't it? Right.
Like, tip, yes. Like,
you could be doing analysis
and open source products,
but there's no open source
tool quite the same. It's connect.
You can certainly
string it together,
with a bunch of different
open source products,
but I think our belief would
be it's gonna cost you much less
time and there's much less
money to just buy this thing
that we have built, where
the cost of building,
it is amortized over, you know,
thousands of customers rather than
you having to pay that
cost yourself by developing the
open source solutions from scratch.
Got it. Thank you.
Awesome. Thank you.
Thank you for all these
great questions coming in. Libby,
I see you just asked one that
getting so many hearts and
reactions right now,
so I'm gonna have you
jump in here to ask that.
Sure. I'm always swooping in
with the touchy feely questions.
When JJ was on, he gave
you a lot of credit for the
culture at our
studio now, Posit.
And so I was kind of
wondering if there was anything that you
did, any steps that you took
to kind of make sure that
our studio moved that direction or
kind of could in embody the
stuff that you
hoped culture wise?
I I'm laughing just because
I think that's, like, classic JJ
because I think he's way more
responsible for the culture than I am.
But, you know, I I will
say I think the thing that
that both JJ and I
share is that I think,
like, while we are both,
like, really good programmers that we
don't believe that
makes us, like,
a better human being in any
way, just a skill that we
happen to have, and
that I think, you know,
as people with with the skill,
that's our responsibility to help
the people that we can
help with them.
And it's it's just been so wonderful
working with with JJ and Tarif and,
the whole leadership team
had puzzled over the last ten
years, because I think that
those values are really
strongly instilled now in our,
in our company culture that,
like, we try and do the
right things. You know,
we're a vehicle because we
don't want to optimize for,
you know, short term profits.
We want to be in this
for the long term.
We want to be able to
make, like, right decisions
that help us out in the
community out in the long term,
not just do what's exigent
in the in the moment.
You. Okay. Jumping over
to one on Slido is what
gaps do you see
in the ecosystem. For example,
most deep learning and
AI applications are built with
Pytorch, sensor flow, and Carys.
Do you see r catching up?
Yeah. I
I don't see up
catching up there.
I think that the the the
pipe that there's just such a huge
community there.
That r is never going to
catch up, and that's fine. Like, it
doesn't have to be good at
everything. R is r is not python.
Can be good at, like, you know,
a set of really important
tasks that doesn't have to embrace
it. And It can do that
because, you know,
our responder means they just
sort of glue language that
there's no sense amongst our users
that are must be the only
language you use.
You, you know,
you use it as much as it helps
you, and then you use the
tools, like, reticulates and talk with
Python and all of the, you know,
the building stuff that's going to
see in c plus plus and new
stuff that's going to rust
and go that, you know,
you talk to the whatever systems
your data lives in, from are,
and then you benefit from
this environment that I believe is
just unparalleled
for fluid interactive
data exploration.
Jesse, I see you had a question
in the chat a bit earlier.
Do you wanna jump in
here? And at some point,
because we have so many,
I might need to say
first and last names.
But as Jesse Osman,
I can ask I can ask the
question if you wanna add any
context, feel free.
But the question was
when writing books using quarto,
Are there any helper packages
that you would use to help
format those files to actually look
like books And how do you
get those quarto files
print ready? Yeah.
That's a good question,
and the answer depends a
lot on kind of exactly what
your target is for the book
and kind of where your skills lie.
So, like, for the
cocktail's book, that's
self published,
hopefully. Obviously,
there's no I'm not signing
up with cocktail book, publishers,
and I did that that a lot
of that is kind of custom. Like,
it uses quarto, but it
a lot of customization,
with latex.
Using my limited, legit
skills, and much googling
and some chat GPT
to get things.
Working.
But other stuff,
like the, like,
if you're publishing
with O'Reilly,
our quota can output the
SD doc, which what O'Reilly uses.
Other publishers, like
more scientific publishers,
you will need to create a
PDF, typically using latex,
and then you'll need to do
some customization yourself.
I think, like, that, that,
that tool change from laser
to PDF is kind of still,
the the the best formed route.
Obviously, it requires
some understanding of late
I will say that is
both, like,
impossible to gain any
meaningful understanding of
late deck without probably
decades of work. But fortunately,
like googling and copying and
pasting and some fair amount of
frustration will where you find
what you want because pretty
much everything you want,
someone has already done.
And it's just a
matter of, like,
finding the right snippet to
paste in and hope it doesn't
conflict with the other
stuff. Get pasted there.
I I think, like,
like, latex is
definitely in the past.
I think we're seeing kind
of more tools like page down,
where you can render,
like, you know,
PDF kind of quality
outputs using HTML engines,
that you know, I think,
solve one set of problems
and introduces another now you're
gonna learn something like
CSS for customization.
But I think we'll see more and
more of that in in the future.
I also just don't really
think about, like, I still think,
like, the primary
version of my books
is the online version.
I think that is
what most people read,
and I just think about the
physical box as kind of like a
nice offshoot that I don't I
honestly don't really care about because
I do not read physical
books anymore. So
I know I know some people
do it. It's nice to have them,
but it's just the
online version,
I think it's so
much more important.
I love all this conversation
happening in the chat right now
too. And just wanna say,
if you're joining us
for the first time,
that's where a lot of people
end up meeting each other too
and, like, sharing helpful
links with each other too.
So feel free to jump in there.
And thank you to deposit folks
in the back end who are helping
me pull out some
of the questions from there.
Alan, I see you had asked
the oh, sorry. You go ahead.
Can I pull one out?
Yes. Go ahead. So,
so I'm asking about these,
which are actually,
embroidery.
It's Lagerz by, Charlotte
Galpan. So I have a lot of,
and, things like that
that I you might see my,
like, a grocery distribution
Halloween. Love it.
Plusy.
I'm thinking back
to the the hex
dress that I saw at
the r studio conference one time.
The amazing things people
make with the hexes.
I think the most imprisons,
oppressive conflated,
thing I saw was like Someone had,
like, tidyverse xs painted on their nails
that they'd done themselves,
but that was really,
really impressive to
do it. That's more.
Absolutely.
Alan, I see you had a
question here in the chat.
Do you wanna jump in?
I do. I were you look I
put in a couple, Rachel,
were you I've only
a specific one?
You could ask your favorite
one, but I see that,
people who are
coming or -- Oh. --
up voting your b core question.
I'll go with the most
recent one. Yeah.
The the b core point.
I'm I'm curious heavily if
as a in the B corp landscape,
are there, like, are there
peers that look like Posit or
doing similar things, or
are you alone. And, like,
what's that like to either
have some sort of well traveled
ground to follow, or is it
figuring out, like, every day,
like, strategically,
what is positive as a B corp
do in this kind of situation?
And it is and I'm
sort of curious if that's, like,
liberating or if
it's terrifying,
like, well, like,
what's that like kind of to
think about operationally being in that space?
I'd say we we
do some benchmarking against other
v corps and the places
where benchmarks are typically
available. Like I know we do.
Like our employee kind of
satisfaction survey as we bench
that to benchmark those
against other b corps.
But I didn't I didn't
I mean, also,
I don't I don't really know if
there are big b corps like us.
I suspect there are not. There
are just not that many, like,
software b corps that, not that
many open source companies.
And
I guess that I don't know.
That that feels kinda like
more freeing to me than worrying.
You know,
certainly it lists a lot of what
we do is just to standard, you know,
there's a a lot of it's
just kind of standard software business.
Playbook.
But at the same time, we
don't have this, like, more about
removing this drive to optimize
short term profitability
that gives us a
room to kind of,
you know, do the things that
we believe to be right, you know,
as much as possible. It's
not always possible to, you know,
it's it's like Like,
what is right is
a very complicated question,
especially as the size of a
company grows. But certainly, we, you know,
we we have the more freedom
to kind of think about that and
add on that. And
while, you know,
certainly we still make
mistakes, I think everyone is,
you know, trying,
trying to absolute best.
Thanks. Appreciate
hearing that. Anne Harris,
I see you asked a
question here in the chat.
You wanna jump in next?
Sure. I'll hop on real quick.
And good effort on the last name.
Oh, sorry. Don't know. Can
you tell me how to say it?
It's like Ferris,
just with the w.
So you've taken a lot
of solutions to massive pain
points that are challenging
and non obvious.
I know if I tried to
do something like GG plot, I
would make no
progress whatsoever.
So I wonder How do you find
your starting points for
implementation? Like,
where do you start from and
how do you measure your progress
and make sure you're moving
towards your end goal?
Good question.
It it feels like a lot of
the packages that I
work on just have this,
the sense of inevitability
about them, but these are
just things that, like,
frustrate me and typically have
frustrated me for years before,
like, some kind of solution
crystallizes in my head.
And then it's just
a matter of, like,
a lot of iteration.
And, you know, now I
think one of the the huge
advantages I have
is that, you know,
there's a peep there's a
community of people who are
willing to try out,
like, whatever crap I produced,
and give me, like, feedback and
tell me, like, you know, this
doesn't work, or this, I
don't understand this. Well,
this is inconsistent
with another tidyverse thing.
And that is just I find
that that kind of a direction, like,
personally, like, you
know, highly motivated.
That people care when
people care enough to,
like, critique it, I find
that to be, yeah, really motivated
So I think that
that it's just that.
And, some weird part of
my brain that is just, like,
collecting these little pain
points. And after a while,
realizing that all of
these pain points, like,
maybe there's some root cause that
they could fix all at once.
Other times, it's like
it's just rub, you know,
knock them off one by one
and then hope something falls out.
Yeah. And there's just this.
I still feel like a lot of
packages just feels like I feel
like there's a sort of
compulsion to create them that
occurs inside of me at
some point in my life. Alright.
So it feels like you're
a force of nature then.
So a slide o question somebody
had asked was Do you have
any recommendations for
teaching non coder
data generators that it's good
to use tidy structured data so
we can use their data
so much more easily.
Yeah. I think the
I like the challenge with
teaching anything this as always,
you you have to figure out
what are the benefits to them,
not what are the
benefits to you,
because the benefits to you
are typically very obvious,
but are not motivating.
To other people. So you
you need to figure out, like,
what's some angle where
by adopting these new ideas,
can they save themselves work?
Or can they produce something
cool? And and maybe that's,
like, if if it's
not about saving,
if you can't find any way that
it's gonna save them work,
maybe there's something you
can do with the type beta
automatically to produce
some kind of useful plot or
motivating figure that will
kind of help them say like, oh,
this is you know, this is kind
of fun. So I think, yeah, like,
try and make it easier or
try and make it more fun,
anything else. Like, it's it's
a hard to hard road to get
other people to to change their
mind and to change their processes.
David Meza, I see you
asked a question in chat.
Do you wanna jump in here next?
Hi, David. And I apologize.
My video is not working. Hey,
Adley. How are you doing? Mhmm. Good.
One of the quest I
had two questions.
One of them was around
tidy models in vetiver.
They've done a lot of good work
on trying to expand the ML ops
in an organization.
Any thoughts or or about what
may be happening in the future?
How do we can get better
ML ops in organization using process?
Yeah. It's a good question. And,
I mean, I I think sort of
hope is, like, as we get
better at integrating our open source
tools and our
professional tools,
some of that would just kinda
happen Naturally, I think
that's, you know,
one of the things we are
struggling with or struggle
with as an organization is,
like, how do we help these,
like, feel the disparate
teams with quite different cultures,
like work together and create
solutions that, you know,
work for people out
in the real world.
So I I think that that
sort of feels to me, like,
with sync pieces are. Like,
we wanna deliver these, like,
end to end solutions, which,
like, just work. And if we
can, you know, make
model deployment,
really easy model
deployment and monitoring,
really easy for you. I think
people will use it more.
Thank you. I think
a lot of chat about,
hex tattoos, different
pausing, our studio tattoos in
there. This isn't exactly tattoos.
I'll show you this other.
This is one of my favorite.
This is a gift from,
my friend and colleague
Winston. It says in case.
That's kinda hard to see
that in case of emergency,
break glass, and it's
brass knuckles with tidy
on one data on the other.
Nice.
Let's see. So many
great questions here.
Trying to trying to get
to everybody. I see Jake.
You asked a Jake Riley. You
asked a question here in the
chat. Oh, yeah.
I know that there's other
packages under the tidyverse,
like Liberty date was a
separate package that you would
have to load. So the
tidyverse was not included.
I was curious you pick
which packages come along,
and I'm hoping glue is next.
Glue is not nixed because you
can already kinda get to it
using STR. Glue because
it's that's re imported through.
Like,
glue is a little bit of a
tricky candidate because it was
kind of designed to be
Well, maybe
yeah. I think glue I don't
know. Glue just feels like too small
to be, like, at this level,
especially when you can get to, like,
ninety five percent of the
functionality by STR underscore glue.
So, generally,
yeah, I think, like,
the tidy list now
is I don't, like,
I don't see any much likelihood
that the membership is gonna change.
The next couple of years,
just because Labor Day,
that that's been a goal to
get Liberty at the tidyverse, but
you know, like, something like
five years. Now, and finally,
kind of, all the, like,
various bits that we had
to deprecate and fix in various
places kinda thought mature enough
we could pull it pull
the trigger on that. But,
so for something else to be
out of the tidy verse, like,
we'd have to be, you
know, start work now,
and it would happen
in a couple of years,
and there's nothing on
on the table currently?
Ben asked a question.
I think Ben maybe had to
drop for another call,
but I'm gonna so I'll ask
it. But the question was,
While I'm bought into
developing open source packages
to help deliver
better processes,
any advice to those of
us doing that development
in getting their
company buy in?
Again, it's like, how do
you, like, you've gotta give
some benefit to the
people using this.
And you've gotta, like, either remove
pain or add fidget in some way.
Because if you can't do
that and you're not someone's, like,
direct supervisor with a lot
of direct power over there,
it's hard to get people to
change. So I I think, like, to
me, a lot of it, like, well,
the way I think about
the tidy versus, like,
how do we give people
some sort of, like, quick wins
so they can be motivated to
do the stuff that are like slower
with where they're gonna
have to learn more, like,
learn some new ideas
or some new tools.
So that you kind of build
up some kind of equity with
that person. Like,
they they've got us in trust
that you've helped them in the
past and now they're willing to
invest like a little bit more
time before they see the
payoff. But in the early days,
it's all about, like,
delivering payoffs as
quickly as possible.
And I think if you're
doing, like, you know, your, like,
my company's first star
package, like, that they the
easy pain points are, like,
make themes for your company
corporate style guide, like make
a g g dot two theme,
make an hour, mark
down a quarter theme,
make a shiny theme that people
can just use to get, you know,
something that's reasonably
close to whatever your
corporate style guide dictates.
And that's just like a that
just feels like an easy win for
people because it makes, like,
of them look good
inside the corporation.
And because you've put
in all the hard work,
it's like three seconds for
them to type the right function
name to get the right theme.
And then I think the
other bit is, like,
make it easier to
get access to data.
Like,
so set up some wrappers
around DBI connections to the most
important data sources provide
some conventions around authentication
so that stuff just works
so that they're not, like,
you're not struggling, like,
how do I what package do
I need to install? Like,
what's password. There's the path
I need. Just give them
some, like, a list of the
top ten most common data sources.
And Like, people will will
love you by and large.
Thank you. Britney, I
see your hands raised.
Do you wanna jump in here next?
Yeah. I actually had a
similar question to Ben,
and I maybe try to phrase a
little differently. So when you
are thinking about sort
of developing maybe that first
package for your company
or something of that nature.
Once you identify the things that
you think would be useful for people.
Do you have, like,
a philosophy or a way in which
you approach kind of putting things together?
Because I know one of the
pain points as you're developing, you realize,
oh,
but what I did originally
doesn't quite work and not to
tear it down and kinda
build it back up again.
So I don't know if you Yeah.
Have lessons learned from
developing so many packages
that we could learn from.
Yeah. That's
I think it's a tough
one because I think
Like, as a team,
we have got, like,
vastly better at dealing with
kind of deprecations and breakages.
And I was reminded of
this recently because I had to
rebuild the first edition
of alpha data science,
and it just worked,
like, five years later,
all the code in that
book still works,
which is certainly not like
true, like five years ago,
if you tried to do that
with five years of code and the
title is it wouldn't
have worked.
And, you know,
I think that that that's
obviously great to have that,
but it's also, like, a
huge amount of extra work.
To do that. And, like,
we can kind of afford to
spend that work because now we're a
team of, like, you know, just
at least my team is, like,
six plus full time people who
can spend their time thinking about this.
Because I think
there's really, like,
when you're in a
environment of, like,
scarcity when you've
only got, like,
so much time that you can take
out of your kind of, like,
everyday job to invest
in writing a package.
Like, it's really tough to
balance. Like, how do I, like,
add new stuff versus making sure
the old stuff continues to work?
So I don't have any
great advice there. I I think,
again, some of it's
about coming, like, building up
trust. So, like, give people some
wins so that when you do
inevitably break stuff,
like, how to accidentally
or on Christmas,
you've got some, like,
kind of cushion that so
people aren't gonna get, like,
really angry with being here
right away. They're gonna be
like, oh, okay. Well, you know,
there's a little bit
of suffering now,
but this person saved
me so much time,
that it's not so bad.
But yeah, it's really hard.
And particularly as
you're starting out, like,
you're gonna make mistakes.
Like, that's inevitable.
And you're gonna do things
that when you look back a year
later, you're like, why on earth
did I do it that way?
And now you wanna, like,
rip out the whole thing and
ride it from scratch. And I
think that, like, if
it feels horrible,
but you have to remember,
like, that's great.
It means you've grown
immensely as a programmer.
And certainly if you have,
like, my kind of mindset,
you have to, like, resist
the temptation to, like,
rip things out and redo them
as much as possible and just focus
on making the next
generation better rather than breaking
what what what stuff
people already have.
So I I don't have any
great answers here,
but I think you just gotta
think about those tensions of, like,
how do I keep my forward
velocity up while like getting
better as a programmer,
well, may be evolving over
time, but, you know, things in
the also thinking about how do
you make the things you did a
long time ago better? Thank
you for that. Thank you.
I see there are a
few questions that mention chat, UPT,
one was from Ian, Ian,
what is your opinion on
how it will evolve the data
scientist's role
in an organization.
Well, I will caveat
my remarks with I
I would say ninety nine
percent of my chat GPT use
is entirely frivolous.
I use it to make things rhyme.
I use it to make things
sound like pirates.
I use it to make things sound
like Southern Grandmars.
We use a lot of country folk sayings.
I use it to make acrostics
with people's names.
I use it now without by
the finance person I work with, I
submit requests exclusively in
the form of office screenplays.
So I I like I don't
know. I think it's, like,
incredibly fun for
stuff like that.
When I have tried the
use of a programming,
it's been like hit o miss.
Like, sometimes it's great, and
sometimes it spits out
something that looks like
totally plausible but is
utterly wrong. So it's, and
it's hard for me to tell, like,
is that just like Is that check
GPD today? And in,
like, in a year's time,
it's gonna be much better?
Or is it gonna be, like,
self driving cars
where, like, kind of,
always coming like a year in the
future, and we never quite get there.
Self driving cars is something I
think about a lot because I
have a Tesla And whenever
I park it on the garage,
it thinks the random collection of
tools hanging on the wall is
a semi, like, about to crash
into us. And I'm like, it can't
even handle like this,
and people say we're gonna
have self driving cars.
So I don't know what time
for me to say. I'd say overall,
I'm kind of like of skeptic.
I think it is gonna be useful.
I think it's particularly
probably it's hard for me to
say like, in some ways,
it's gonna be really useful.
When you're learning because you
can take the things that
are words in your ear and
split them out and say, like,
how do I rotate the access
labels on the g g block and you
get something
pretty reasonable,
which makes it super
useful for learning.
But at the same time
as you're learning,
it's gonna spit out stuff
that looks totally plausible,
but is totally wrong,
and you're in the worst
possible situation to try and
figure out what's going on.
So
I I do not. We'll see. I
think it's super exciting.
I have a lot of fun with it,
but I do not use it
all professionally.
Yeah.
It seems like there's a lot
of people who think those are
great use cases of it.
The way you're using it.
Let me go over. I will
say recently, we had a company
meeting recently. We had
some customers come on,
and I took their bios.
And just made chat GPT
make them rhyme and the people
were, like, so impressed.
So impressed. I'm like, I just my
check t p t make a rhyme.
But, I see there's a lot of,
conversation beneath
you's question. You, do
you wanna jump in here?
Hi. Hi, Hallene. That's a
really big fan of your work.
So my question is,
what's the implementation plan of
our on cloud computing platform?
So my team works in Azure.
And, actually, it's using our data.
It's very inconvenient
advice. So be previously,
before we moved to Azure,
the work my team has seventy
percent in our thirty percent in Python.
After moving to a zero, right,
quickly turn to seventy
percent in Python,
thirty percent in
So Python is just,
wired natural option
for modeling analysis there.
So does policy have any plan
to change this in the future?
Yeah. I mean, I
don't know if change.
It's quite the right phrase because
I know if we have the,
like, the power to do
that. But, certainly, you know,
what we are trying to do is
make are as easy as possible to
use every way you can possibly use it.
And I, you know, I think
thinking about, like,
is more and more people
move to car computing.
How can we make it easy to
get set up and get configured and
make things just work
is really important.
I know, like,
one example at the moment
is we're working on a partnership
with with Databricks to
make using our inside Databricks
clusters much much easier
certainly,
like, this seems like
there's a lot of, like,
just challenges getting things set
up there that, you know,
folks have kind of solved
on the Python side.
And no one has put the time
in to solve them on the outside.
So I'm hoping that,
you know, as a company,
we'll continue to invest in
in those opportunities just make
it easy to use for everyone.
Lisa, I see you had a question
earlier on Fuji plot two.
Do you wanna jump in? Sure.
I think I asked two
questions about g d flat two,
but I think I'll go with
the first one, which is,
sort of how do
you feel about it
people contributing
having so many people
to contributing
to that package and like all the
add ons that I've come from you.
Sort of like any
any things that
sort of amazed you.
And then on the opposite
side, any sort of major frustrations.
Yeah. I mean,
I think the thing that's kind
of kind of blows my mind about
g g pop two is it's like
coming up So it's it's gonna come up
to its eighteenth
birthday. Clearly, soon,
so I'm sort of joking about
that will be time to, like,
emancipate it, and it's
gonna just tip the like,
survived by itself from now on.
And kind of
realistically, like,
I'm not that involved
in the day to day.
Management of
Judyville too anymore.
That torch is gonna be passed
to to to Thomas Peterson. It
was now, you know, starting to
get, you know, like, I guess,
And like four years
ago, I was, like,
sick of maintaining kiki
boat tour, like, a long ago,
sick of maintaining
a high Thomas.
And now Thomas is just
kidding. Recommendating. So we've gotta,
like, figure out
what to do next.
But yeah, like maintaining something
that is, like, so popular
is, you know, both a blessing
and a curse. It's like
incredible to know
that, you know,
literally millions of people have
used it and attack them
you know, make graphs and
make your life easier,
but it also is like
immensely challenging to make any changes
because like so many people rely
on it now and are used to
the the defaults.
So there's there's
something, like, I think both
I don't know if I can quickly
pull this up. But, like,
one thing I think
about a little
a little bit from time
to time is just, like,
how many people Like,
if I find the most
popular yeah.
So the most popular page on the g
g pop two website is the g on
bar documentation.
Which fifteen thousand people have
read in the last month.
Like, there are not many
ways you can reach like,
you can have more of an impact
on people's lives than by
looking at that page about
five jobs and thinking,
how can we make that data?
But at the same time,
those changes tend to be kind
of small and incremental.
So it's also, like,
fun to, like, you know,
embark on completely new
projects that no one uses so
you're free to do
whatever you want.
And in some ways,
I think, like,
the the ecosystem of packages
is kind of it takes a
combination of those strengths
and those weaknesses because
like g g pot two can,
like, stay the same and stable,
whereas you can
continue to, like,
build on top of it with
these packages that fewer people use,
but are also, like, much more
easier to change and and and
flexible. So I definitely have,
like, mixed feelings about like
this, but both, like, a
it's awesome, like, when people use
my stuff and, you know,
they just they feel so good,
but it's also like, oh,
now I have to, like,
answer their questions,
and they can't just change
things really nilly.
So I also do like work
on things that no one uses.
That's also a different a
different kind of fun. Adly,
something that's, like,
stood out in my mind that
I've learned from you, from internal
company calls is how you
handle focus time and the
way you you manage
your own time.
And I thought it might be
helpful just to chat a little
bit about that and to share
how you think about that?
Yeah. I one sort of one funny
and I go I gave a talk about
this idea of focus time,
and a couple of years ago,
it would be now at the
company. And I was like,
I feel like the truest
expression of my philosophy
would be to say, no,
I'm not gonna give a talk about
focused time because that's
gonna interrupt my
work for the day.
But I I really try
to, like, create a lot
of time for, like,
uninterrupted
work. Because I think,
you know, like, programming is,
like, fundamentally
creative work,
and, like, finding the time
to kind of, like, process
and take things through
is is really important.
So what my what I do currently
is I, like, every day,
as I said, I try and, like,
first thing I do, like,
get up and write for a couple
of hours or an hour at least.
That's like the time of the
day where I am most productive.
And so I wanna spend all the
things that I think are most important.
Know, not the things that
are necessary most urgent.
And then, you know,
I have a team,
so I have to I have to talk
to the But and I have to talk to
my colleague that's positive, of
course, I love talking to,
but it means I
can't do other work.
So my kind of compromise is I've walked
two days a week off on my calendar,
Tuesdays and Thursdays where I
try really really hard not to
do new things. You know,
sometimes if there's, like,
a bigger meeting that
has, like, fifteen people,
and it's impossible to find
the time otherwise I'll do it,
but I'm really generally pretty
good at about keeping those
days clear so I can
tackle bigger problems. And I think
that's, you know,
really important.
It's it's of course
challenging because you have,
when you've got a big
four hour block of time,
you still have to, like,
train yourself to, like,
resist the temptations
of TikTok and
Master's on or certainly, but
temptation of Twitter has been
totally removed from me today,
these days. So I guess that's Good.
But certainly, like,
you have to train yourself to
lay and it's, you know, hard
to, like, stay focused
on one thing and,
not given to all the other
more fun distractions that you have
around you, but giving
yourself that space, I think,
is really important.
Thank you so much.
I know this hour always goes
by very quickly. And there's so
many great questions.
So maybe I can collect those
and share them with you at some
point, hardly, and we can think
about how to answer them all.
No.
But another question that I'd love
to ask you is Are there
any books you'd recommend to
this audience here or resources
you'd recommend that have been
useful for you in your career?
Yeah. Let me show you.
Let's see if I can find
the ones I like, the
motor size keep around.
I don't know if I keep
This is one of the books
that's kind of been inspiring or has
inspired the tidyverse, design
book, it's called
a pattern language.
It's actually a book about
architecture and how you design houses,
It's just a really, like, you
know, it's a very thick book,
but it's designed to
be kind of skimmable.
I think it's just it's sort
of fun and interesting to read
about in this, like,
system of the describing
all of these components,
the different
levels of hierarchy,
and how you can join
them together, I think, is very
much, connected to programming.
I'll also say, like, one one
reason not to stop reading physical books.
It's like a Hello. Look at
these folks now, and I'm like,
oh my god. Why is
the font so small?
But it's because I am
becoming middle aged
and becoming increasingly each
outside of each sex.
I don't know.
I think that that's the book
I've been thinking about, like, the most
lately. Some of the
other ones, I guess,
Got it right up
because I had
delimited book space,
and I kinda like keeping these.
And also, this collection of, like,
you know, c l a historical books.
This is, like, from
nineteen twenty three.
Because there's just so much,
like, when you kind of look
back at what people were doing,
like, a hundred years ago,
Like, I think it's really
revealing that in many cases, like,
the quality of visualizations
is not improved.
Them much. Like,
the quality of the best
visualization does not improve
a huge amount in the
last hundred years.
About the ease of making
them. Like, now you can, like,
whip out fifteen variations in
g g blood in fifteen minutes.
Whereas before you were
at a, like, painstaking,
you need to draw them
all out with pen and ink.
So I think it's just
sort of interesting to
reflect on that a
little bit and, like,
what's what's changed really in visualization
month in the last hundred years?
I know we're at the
end here, but maybe one inspirational,
question to ask you.
What's something that you're you're most
excited about as you think about,
maybe the the tidyverse and
pause it going forward? I mean,
I I am, like,
a legitimate they're really
excited about us embracing Python
more. You know, I'm still lucky
to be accusing Python, but I've
We went to a Python conference
recently and talked to a bunch
of people using Python,
and I'm just excited about
helping out all these type in
using data scientists because it
just feels like this this
product, like, it just works type stuff.
There's just a huge huge scope
for there. And I'm, you know,
excited to kind of help spread
that, like, the positive way of
doing things, the
positive kind of community
how we think about people
and try and, you know,
spread that you further
further in the world.
Thank you so much, Hadley.
Is that our new slogan?
It just works?
I I think it should
be. Well, well,
I know not like we're
certainly not there everywhere,
but I just think that's like,
that's what the the best
experience you can deliver is
you just try something
out and it works.
And people stop remarking on
that because it just works.
They don't have to
think about that.
And I think that's and we'll say
I think some of the best packages
that me and my team
created or almost invisible because they
just make problems go away,
and you never need
to think about them.
You never need to know
about them because that's just some
pain you never
need to experience.
And then you can just
listen to all the old,
but cranking on about how
terrible it was back in the day
and how they had drugged
fearful to school.
Three feet of snow,
and just listen to their
stories and be happy.
You you don't live
in that environment anymore anymore.
Thank you so much. Again,
for joining us today, Hadley.
And and thank you all so
much for for joining the hangout
today and and making
this space what it is.
Pretty impressive to have over
two hundred people on a Zoom
call and not have to worry
about what's happening and make
you all for monitoring the space too.
It If this was your first hangout,
we would absolutely love to
have you join us again. So,
again, they happen
every Thursday.
Same time, same place.
I'll put the link again where you
can just add it to your calendar.
But next week, we'll be
joined by Mike Lopez,
senior director of football data
and analytics at the NFL
So he'll be our our
featured leader next week.
And if you have any questions
about it or wanna reach out to
me. Feel free to connect
on LinkedIn as well.
Thank you all so much
for joining today,
and have a great Great rest
of the day. Great rest of the
week. Bye everybody. Thanks,
Rachel. Thanks everyone. Bye.